e
okay thre minute warning we're going to
get started in in three
minutes
e
stay Federal we usually try to start
right on time uh I'm waiting for the
ranking members she'll be back in the
moment so we will uh come to order at
this time and I'd like to ask uh
representative who is um retiring so to
speak or won't be back for a while
that's representative
pumani uh represent Pani if you would
lead us in the pledge we would be much
obliged
great job representative much obliged
okay today we have two measures they're
both interim study measures they are HB
1041 relative to establishing a
commission to investigate the USS
Liberty incident and its aftermath and
then secondly is HB 1485 establishing a
committee to study the totality of
circumstances surrounding the covid-19
epidemic so uh Madame clerk if you have
a note from the from the house clerk if
you could just read that so it's clear
uh this is uh we're not voting on bills
today we're not voting on resolutions
we're voting on interim study
recommendations uh if you could read
that please okay this is from uh clerk
Paul C Smith this is a reminder as we
enter interm study it's important to
remember there are two opt options
recommended for future legislation or
not recommended for future legislation
additionally given the nature of things
this term a reminder that your committee
ends up deadlocked on these
recommendations then it can be reported
without
recommendation however for interm study
we do not have two separate statements
the chair should write a simple
statement as the committee report such
as the committee was unable to reach a
consensus of whether to recommend future
legislation or not so that is the advice
clerk thank you madam committee clerk
okay at this time uh I want to thank the
members from this committee who did
serve on the subcommittee that met uh to
go over these two measures that we did
refer to interim study and thank you
represent Manion for chairing uh both of
those efforts uh so at this time uh
representative man I'm going to look to
you uh to uh
to start with the uh HP 1041 the USS
Liberty incident and I'm looking for a
motion and then sub we'll have
subsequent discussion uh I move uh
recommend for future legislation
second move by representative Manion for
uh favorable future legislation seconded
by representative Gagney uh rep Manion
uh would you please speak to your motion
absolutely thank you Mr chair so uh we
went over the bill and we all understood
that when the bill when we first put it
into the interim study that the bill
itself as written had issues especially
with like the membership there was
people who came here and testified and
said they didn't want anything to do
with being on the commission so for
future legislation one of our
suggestions would be that it be scoped
down to be like a house committee with a
much smaller scope in that respect and
uh one of the important things is
whatever the outcome of this it needs to
be sent the the output report needs to
be sent to our federal delegation
because they should use this as
something that they need to use the
powers that they have at their level to
investigate further there's only so many
things that we're going to be capable of
doing as a state we don't have access to
a lot of this information so whatever we
do what whatever testimony we record
that should be sent to our federal
delegation thank you representative I
want to say a couple words about the
measure I know there are there are some
people who are watching and will'll
watch so what this measure had had to do
with what it involved D HB 1041 was an
incident in the Mediterranean Sea in
1967 during the 6 Day War uh between
Israel and its uh surrounding uh Arab
states and the USS celebrity was a uh
American Naval vessel that was attacked
by the Israelis and and many uh American
Sailors were injured and killed uh the
ship was badly damaged and this was uh
in 196
67 uh Israel subsequently
apologized uh but there have have
been issues and questions that have
lingered obviously we're talking about
it here in 2024 in this committee room
and so this measure was brought forth by
the sponsors and uh you'll all recall
there were some survivors of that ship
who traveled great distances uh from
Missouri and Virginia to come here to
speak to the and in their Hope was that
uh we would take some sort of action
that would more than just shine a light
on what happened but uh would be an
impetus for for some action um that
would be meaningful to uh provide some
redress to the survivors and to the
memories of those who are uh lost so we
spent a lot of time on this in committee
as you'll recall and uh we ended up
referring it to interim study and uh and
thank you represent Manion for your
initial comments uh represent Gagner you
seconded the motion and I believe you
and you also were on the
subcommittee uh and you also are a Navy
man do you do you have some thoughts or
some words to the
motion I do my bottom line question
would be for the federal
delegation is why was there a gag order
imposed on the crew crew and on the on
the Jag officer who investigated this
incident why
was the people involv those who were
wounded and the
survivors number one why was that ship
unescorted I believe this is my opinion
I believe that the administration at the
time didn't want to start anything U
that would lead to
International
conflict and that's my opinion I am pro-
Israel however I know what a flag looks
like when it's flying from midships it's
big enough to be seen for like a mile
away so uh why was that done and why was
it my term whitewashed by the uh
American uh administration at the time
and I'll offer another comment myself
and of course everybody here is uh is
welcome to weigh in as well I think uh
Mo a lot of us are I am a history person
many of you are as well and I see value
uh in uh shining a light on this
important history in this part of the
world Israel has been very much
prominently in the news uh forever but
particularly since a year ago October
7th and in this a war wars going on
there in that part of the world now and
and we have people deployed there
Americans are in that theater so just
the fact that we are talking about this
and there are some people listening uh
raises awareness about some of the
history there some of the military
people who uh we lost and uh I think
it's important to use this to have us
pay more attention to this part of the
world that is uh is so important so
there are some thoughts from me other
thoughts or comments or questions for
the uh subcommittee chair representative
sherff uh thank you Mr chairman just a
question for you representative Manion
and that is has any other state passed
this
legislation not that I'm aware of no
okay thank you thank you the qu that's a
good question that's one that I posed uh
formally and informally to some of the
veterans who came here and we're always
interested in what other states do with
with things that we're looking at and uh
to my knowledge to our knowledge no
other state has has taken the action
that we've been asked to take here
followup Mr chair sure um if this
legislation should pass
how much could a committee actually do
you wouldn't be aering anyone other than
maybe hearing some of the Shipmates uh
that went through this ordal and my
heart is with them as a veteran
um and I just worry it be giving them
faults feeling that something's finally
after 67 years could to be
accomplished thank you for that
representative if this we're going to
vote on it shortly if this were to be
recommended for future action then
someone depends who's in the mix who
gets elected uh it would be up to
someone an original sponsor or someone
sympathetic to the original intent would
need to uh uh submit uh an LSR and and
the language uh I think would be
different I think the language would
reflect some of the recommendations we
just heard from the subcommittee chair
so to your to your good question uh as
to where this might go uh it's kind of
to be determined it would depend upon
who wants to take the time to sponsor it
and work up some new langu with with
OLS thank you um Mr subcommittee chair
uh you heard the question what do you
say to that I think we've also made it
very clear as a committee like even when
the gentlemen were here testifying
before us that there was not much as the
state of New Hampshire we can do like we
can what we could do is have them come
in testify on the record we'd have it
filmed in for posterity it' be on the
internet forever and we can send those
things to the federal delegation where
they would have much more resources they
can call upon they can issue subpoenas
and get the information that they're
looking for but it's it's kind of like
um those guys have been going around and
and we're like the first state to
actually take them seriously what
they've been doing for like decades now
is just they go on podcasts wherever
they can try to get their message out
there but that's like the limitation
this is like a level up from that I
think and it's showing them more respect
than just relegating them to like the
podcast
sphere and that's a comment that I made
to them when they were here I said uh
we're listening to you uh this is New
Hampshire every Bill gets a hearing and
you need to know as you heard me tell
them uh as represent Manning just said
uh you're being heard and in perpetuity
the uh the recording the YouTube is out
there I'm sure they've looked at it and
shared it and that's uh if nothing else
that they've their voice has been given
um has been heard any other uh comments
Rollins thank you Mr chairman my feeling
is that we owe all these men on this
ship
an answer to what happened that day so
that they know so that these men can
have finally have closure after all
these years that's all I have to say
they they do they need
closure thank you representative
anything
else seeing No Hands Madam clerk I do I
do I'm sorry cber your red light is on
yes yeah okay all right um no I just um
it seems like also something we could
have already done like send them the the
recording we already have right to our
federal delegation and ask them these
questions just a thought also you know
yeah thank you representative so I don't
know that we have specifically because
we haven't finalized action on this
measure we haven't um sent anything
formally to the to the de delegation but
uh I think that uh once we vote on this
I think would be appropriate to to uh
share the results of the vote and on
this um to that delegation and
elsewhere is that okay yeah I guess yeah
I just I feel bad telling them we can do
something we can't do and then have to
have them come back and testify again I
mean they were already thankful to have
been here once you know and I know the
trip isn't cheap and all that and it's
like it seems like we could have already
done that you know um versus but you
know I get it yeah
okay yes I I I hear you I agree I you
can tell I we're all sympathetic to
these survivors and and and and what
they're trying to accomplish thank you
for that representative Milla I just
think it's important that they realize
we're Limited in what we can do but
we're going to do as much as we can yeah
agree and I think we convey that to them
and I know they appreciated that uh
there were some people that were
listening and and trying to take some
sort of action other comments questions
anything representative L good job
representative Manning on that with the
interim study and getting it this far
because I think a lot of these veterans
really do need to get closure on this
because it's very important to them so
great job R
man agreed as I've already said U thank
you for your work on the subcommittee
represent Lloyd um I just wanted to
thank you uh M or S uh thank you um it's
been a while uh so I I I just wanted to
go on record as saying um I believe that
everybody has the ability to appeal a
decision that they don't feel was
investigated fully and extensively and
um I also uh just wanted to say that I
fully you know appreciate those veterans
who did come out here and I do feel like
they need their closure I would
recommend that if this moved forward in
any type of legislation that the that we
keep in mind the our limited ability as
well um as has already been stated um in
that we don't have the jurisdiction to
investigate this all we can really do is
recommend that others investigate it
with their capability um but that that's
my two
cents yes agreed um
anything
else okay seeing no other hands one last
comment for me there is a New Hampshire
piece to this there were some New
Hampshire people on the ship there's a
high ranking officer who I think very
recently just passed away
who uh yes commander Lewis is that was
that the name right so there were was a
New Hampshire presence on the ship to to
make that uh more relevant to that
measure being heard here anything
else seeing no hands and Madam clerk the
the motion before us is uh ought to pass
in uh in a future iteration of of uh HB
1041 uh if you read the role okay octop
pass future legislation representative
Rollins yes representative lungren yes
representative catoris yes repres
representative levit yes representative
gagy yes representative
ponti yes okay uh representative Manion
yes representative shirtliff yes
representative Mass Milla representative
uh Boris isn't here yes I am oh she is
okay okay um all right representative
Cary yes representative tol is not here
representative Judy not here um
representative Lloyd yes representative
O'Neal is not here representative
Sebert yes yes okay all right and the
chair chair votes yes okay one two three
four five 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 does
that sound right
14 and no
n okay 14 to zero thank you madam clerk
that is our recommendation at 1041 now
our other measure is hb1 1485 that is
with regard to the committee
establishing a committee to study the
totalitar total totality of
circumstances surrounding the covid-19
epidemic again repres Manion uh chaired
that subcommittee that did the interim
study work on this measure uh
representative Manion I look to you for
a motion on on this measure thank you Mr
chair I I'm uh moved that we Rec men for
future
legislation do I have a
second second again uh representative
gagy seconds the uh motion of the
subcommittee chair ranion would you
speak to your motion yes absolutely
thank you um so there is currently a
committee that is studying the New
Hampshire response to this uh the bill I
spoke to the bill uh Prime on this one
and his explanation makes sense to me it
was more this is more about the much
larger scope of uh the circumstances so
it would be like uh the influence from
the federal government uh the efficacy
of op operation warp speed uh any of the
um non-governmental organizations that
may have had influence within the state
whether it be through the state itself
through a um through the towns whatever
like directly circumventing the state um
I I think it's a we decided that it
would be worth investigating once again
we're kind of at the limitation where we
can't get all the information we may
want from the federal government but
it's something that we could definitely
like ask the towns and and things of
those like was there anything not from
the New Hampshire state but perhaps from
the federal government or non-government
organizations that may have influenced
your decisions uh that you made at at
the local
level Rose Manion what was the vote was
it a unanimous vote unanimous 40 both of
these were 40 okay that's what I thought
we had represent gagy you seconded this
do you want toh speak to your
second no I think the subcommittee chair
spoke eloquently enough uh
and I back him
up thank you representative gagy and
thank you for your eloquence uh uh
representative Manion uh questions
thoughts comments from from anyone
represent cber yeah so I watched some of
the videos from the current committee
that is taking place and I actually um
believe they're getting very good
information actually that needed to be
addressed definitely um it turns out
like our state only had you know really
old plans for like hurricane resp
response is what they just referred to
and so there were obviously like gaps in
the system that needed to be dealt with
that type of thing just things need to
be updated and obviously the world has
updated since then so um I believe that
stuff is really good information and
that type of thing we need Solutions we
need to seek in the future for future
legislation I'm not sure how much we
need to really get into the weeds and
how much ends up being just a EXP
exporing conspiracies and seeing which
things fit our narrative at any given
time it seems like a lot that can go
into a lot of different directions as we
saw when we had
testimony and so while opinions are
important I also think that we really
need to directly do what can immediately
affect our citizens and really help them
out if there's a natural disaster or
anything else that can happen you know
within that time frame I I see that
getting done first so thank you thank
you for that in my understanding is the
prime sponsor if he is reelected uh is
interested in taking the your work and
your recommendations and and U putting
something together uh for the next term
questions seeing No Hands then let us uh
take up the motion which is uh ought
ought to pass in the future uh or
version of this should move forward in
ready okay ought to pass future
legislation representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative catoris representative
levit yes representative gagy yes
representative pimonte
yes representative Manion yes
representative shirtliff yes
representative Mass Miller
representative Boris yes representative
Carrie yes representative Lloyd yes
Representative seert no okay so we have
13 yeses oh
chair chair votes I okay 13 yeses and
okay 13 to1 and that concludes uh all of
our business again thank you to everyone
on the uh subcomittees and thank and I
want to take uh before we close out I
want to take uh just a few moments to
thank you all uh for for your work and
for your involvement with with this
committee um I really appreciate it I
think uh we uh spent a lot of time on
over 20 measures not quite what
education deals with but uh we had a
decent load and and obviously we spent a
lot of time on some of these and with a
lot of uh a lot of testimony from many
people who came in that we uh and we
honored the sponsors and those who cared
about all these different measures by
giving them the attention we gave them
um I mentioned representative Pani is is
uh is retiring uh for for now anyway um
and there are others of us who won't be
back uh who knows there is an election
in a couple weeks um uh there's another
member of our committee um who will not
be back that that I'm sure about and if
I'm besides representive Pani if I'm
missing anybody else uh I I apologize uh
but I do want to recognize the uh the
representative from Penacook uh
Representative Steve schliff who uh is
let it be known that he is uh will will
not be in the ballot on November 5th uh
in a couple weeks so I I just want to
thank representative schliff uh in in
express my deep appreciation for your
very helpful role in this committee and
and for all your previous work um I'll
say uh 20 years ago 2004 when I was a
young man um there was another young man
uh I ran for rep uh out of conquer that
year uh and and I noticed uh of course
you notice the other people that are
running and I noticed some of the other
names one of the other names that was
running in conquered was representative
schliff was first time I'd heard his
name and he was in a different district
and um and he was successful he won uh
and I think that was if if my Math's
right that's the first of 10 consecutive
uh uh election victories for the
representative from from Penacook uh I
lost and it took me TW took me 12 years
to uh to get here I always wanted to be
here and 12 years later I I got here now
I am wielding a gavel and speaking um
about representative Sherl so that's all
I just wanted to to say thank you and
acknowledge uh representative Sheriff's
uh uh contributions and I know there's
couple others wanted to say a couple
words this is a little bit like
unanimous consent before I before I G
gel this to an end um in representative
Gagney I actually have some pink cards
um that we'll give to representative
shirtliff with the notes in the back and
representative Gagney uh is she here
right
here
uh uh well I've already said I don't
but representative gagy doesn't doesn't
always asked for the microphone um he's
he's asked he didn't put how many
minutes but he he it's the bill number
just says Steve and uh and R gag said he
uh with your permission Mr chairman I'd
like to
with the witness
protocol and be free to
speak yes uh as a chair I do have some
measure of authority and uh I uh will
grant you permission to speak freely and
or to speak honestly and move about
freely
photos
here
Linda Steve this is not a roast okay
this is a testimonial
of what some of what we went through uh
probably like 37 years before we met
again right when you were chair of
Criminal Justice in
2009 I want you to remember we keep
bringing that up the night before
graduation from the academy remember the
snowball
fight it was fun the guy went down to
assess damage we went crazy night before
because it was like the big release
right that's when that's when the police
academy was very intense wasn't it six
weeks yeah we did more listening than
anything else right Sergeant Sandler was
one of the uh the people there he was he
he became the uh mayor of Nash of the uh
police chief of Nashville for a while um
I I remember my time with you when my
first
time my first term in 2009 you were
chair of Criminal Justice and I was I
remember we talk and I looked at you and
I says I think I know him but I don't I
I but I can't place so I mean we there
was like 30 some odd years
apart I remember looking at him and I
remember talking to you and I remember
telling you that I've got one mouth and
two ears so this term I want to listen
way more than talk and you says that's
very wise it was very wise so in in in
conversation we uh we found out that we
we had graduated you didn't have a
picture and I brought it in and showed
you and you asked me could make a copy
and you made me a copy which is why
they're two going down it it was it was
pretty cool going back somewhat now you
and I have both had flashbacks from
various events you in Vietnam me as a
police officer in
Manchester and I I remember you and I
talked about that without going into any
detail we were able to help each other
out
uh what else do I have to tell tell you
I really really nothing else it's been a
pleasure serving with you uh I remember
I used to be able when you were chair
when you were a speaker I was able to
take my grandkids up to the office and
we had a conversation we may not have
agreed uh politically all that much
however we both love this country and we
we' probably do it again wouldn't we I
think I think so too so I I was not a
Ground Pounder which is why I joined the
Navy I'm a Winnebago kind of guy I
didn't want to crawl through mud and I
don't want I want three squares in a
rack which was already got in the Navy
so I just say that you that was your
first year in the house when I cheal
justice as you remember back then light
may I don't want any BS to hear me rip
Andy will you will you will you take any
will you take any questions absolutely
represent of shirtliff is recognized
what you believe um in 2008 when you
came to the house um and served on
criminal justice uh I made a deal with
the ranking member our good friend David
Welsh that no side would caucus uh the
bills nobody would talk about him the
first hand going up that's we' recognize
and we'd either vote it up or down no
politics and politics stopped at the
door and at the end of the first year my
friend you said to me you know this is
my first year in the house I finished on
our committee I'm still not sure who's a
Democrat and who's a Republican and I
remember saying to you as a committee
chair I could not ask for a better
compliment than that so thank you once
again my friend thank you I salute
you thank you represent gagy and thank
you for the uh usually we don't use
props but uh we're we're we're in a
unique situation today I'm looking at
the photo uh I recognize representative
shli for sure he looks about the same as
rep representative gagy I would never
know this was you in this photo but
uh
200 that's right represent G he was and
is a wrestler I don't think he wrestles
as much as he did I have two more I have
two more pink cards uh uh representative
Carrie uh who right to my left submitted
a pink card and uh representative carrye
is representative Cary is going to to
chair or maybe not represent Carrie is
left the left the
room
[Laughter]
so uh representative shirtliff I met
many years ago um when he was playing
Santa Claus and my children who were
toddlers at the time uh were so thrilled
to meet Santa Claus uh he was
volunteering for a nonprofit in Penacook
the Penacook historical society and
little did I know that our paths would
meet again in the State House more than
once um but as I thought of his service
not only to his community but to our
state I could think of only one symbol
of his service that would be appropriate
it would have to be something made in
New Hampshire and it would have to be
something involving the state house and
so this was made by local artists Diane
Delany and it is for posterity for you
representative Carri I'm going to ask
that you take that and the only camera
that can show what that looks like I
know people want to see what it looks
like if if you would mind taking just a
moment and returning to the uh the chair
and just holding that
so so people can see uh I know there are
watch uh it appears to be a painting of
some
okay that's where you
live so this is um artist Diane She Goes
By Dana uh Delany she is an artist from
Kuka New Hampshire who has a studio in
conquered at the conquered Women's Club
and it is a painting of the skyline of
thank you Carrie I have two more pink
cards uh one is from um uh
representative Rollins who's who's right
here
um so represent Rollins you can uh if
you want to take the uh the witness
looking
guy thank you Mr
chairman uh I told Steve a while ago
last week that I was going to do a roast
on him I planned on two or 3 hours uh
representative mofet came to his rescue
and said I only had a couple of minutes
so I'm going to show this
up before I get started I want everybody
in here to know there's nothing mean
there's nothing vicious about what I'm
saying going to say it's just all about
two guys that came together that became
very good friends that love to rib each
other every time we get
together let make sure I start in the
beginning just got my
highlights when I was when I first
became uh the term was as coach him and
one of my jobs was to do the seating AR
Arrangement and so when I did the
seating arrangement I put Steve being
beside of me as a high ranking the
highest ranking Democrat member halfway
through the session I turned around and
looked at him and I said the real reason
I put you beside of me is so I could
keep an eye on you but I said I've
learned real fast that I really messed
that up because you're the one keeping
an eye on
me and uh let me get down the line
here another time uh Steve was sitting
here before session Linda Miller comes
in and I jumped up and I said Linda I
said get his autograph get his autograph
now she goes what for I go he's famous
what are you talking about I said he was
on Chronicle last night I said for the
the uh conquered hockey arena I said get
his autograph or he starts charging for
it so we all had a good conversation
about the chronicle and everything and
and it was all good um shortly after
after that he gets even with me we're
down in the catheter line okay I'm two
or three people ahead of him all right
and he Bell us out for the whole
catheter to hear Hey everybody you might
as well find another place to eat when
skip in front of us and there's going to
be nothing left to eat by the time we
get through by the time he gets through
the line this is this is the way this is
the way we should get along in this
[Music]
um Surly after that uh I'm going to
shorten this up
um a while back the last session in in
uh committee this year I gave you a PMI
hat like this and I wanted you to have
that I wanted you to have that for your
service as a combat veteran Vietnam
combat veteran what you had to put up
with from the American people was
horrendous I wanted you to have a good
token I know you have friends probably
that you lost people that were over
there that are missing in action wanted
you to has something to remember them by
and it was very important and you were
touched by it and I hope from time to
time you might even wear it okay so
what's he do the next time we're in
session uh he comes over to me and he
hands me a black cloth bag right and
there's something in it and he said I
really appreciate the hat but i' like to
have let you have this this gift as a
thank you to you and I'm feeling this
cloth bag and I'm saying to myself this
feels like a 50 calor round and I said I
know what he's doing he's going to give
me that 50 cal round he's going to go to
security and they're going to drag me
out of
here but when I opened the bag it was a
dummy round it had a notch in it it's a
bottle opener so every every time I will
open a beer I will use that can opener
bottle opener and I will always remember
you okay um about one of the last things
it this this has gone on even to today
but early last week when we were in here
for session I'm back in the L I'm
getting out I'm walking for the door car
comes up so I didn't even look I just
motioned him to go ahead and go ahead of
me Steve rolls down the window he says
skip go ahead he said age before
Beauty and I said Thank you and I
started a walk and then I turned around
and I looked at him like a deer in the
headlights and I said you just want to
run me over don't you and he goes the
thoughts on my mind you better get
moving
Steve we are going to I am all of us are
going to miss you I wish there were more
people like you on both sides of the
aisle where we could all agree to
disagree but still shake hands give a
hug and Raz each other once in a while
you are so going to be missed I hope
from time to time you come by the state
house stop and say hi and uh I wish you
the best in whatever you do the rest of
your life and someday I hope we run into
each other and we can share a beer for
these old time sakes you're a great man
thank you for your
service thank you representative thank
you skip so
much I have one I have one more pink
card uh but some other ones are coming
in um so we we'll uh we'll do what we
always do these pink cards come in and
we will stay here until every person
gets to be heard that's how we do things
in New Hampshire uh the last committee
card I have is from uh representative
massamilla the representative from
Littleton uh the bill again is Steve uh
Ron Massa supports the bill and the and
wants to speak about an eyeglass
incident
apparently thank you Mr chair um this is
just sort of an illustration of Steve's
generosity um I was uncharacteristically
late for session one day and um I
realize as I'm looking in my abyss of my
pocketbook that I don't have my glasses
well everybody knows if you don't have
your glasses that also affects your
hearing so I after looking for a while
and sighing a lot and arm length reading
my um notes
and then pulling my seatmates for spare
glasses um lunch break came along
mercifully for everybody in my
section so after lunch was over um I
came back into the chamber and Steve
sitting there with a paper
bag and in the paper bag there was a
pair of glasses he had gone down to R
Aid and and picked up a pair of glasses
and although the glasses didn't really
set a fashion trend they definitely were
you useful for me and also he saved his
seatmate sanity because I didn't have to
whine anymore so thank you Steve for
your kindness your thoughtfulness and
your
generosity represent will you take any
questions sure represent sure love have
any question or comment for the for the
representative I have a comment you know
I almost thought about calling in to get
a substitute for today and
uh and with mixed emotions I'm so glad
I'm here and uh thank you all for the
very kind words and
uh especially at my R well everybody
being next to me and Larry and you know
when I came to the house 20 years ago
somebody told me there were two great
committees in the New Hampshire house
uh fishing
game and I'm I'm sorry uh Satan fed and
Veterans of fees and one other and uh I
can't remember the other committee but
it is still State and fed and Veterans
Affairs among the top two committees in
this house and I want to thank the
members uh this is committee brought
back members of uh one criminal justice
and uh back when Larry first started in
the house where um we're Democrats and
Republicans but on every Bill we vote on
we always put the best interest of the
people of New Hampshire and uh uh and I
really think I saved my best committee
for last so thank you Mr
chairman thank you for that thank you
representative uh representative go
ahead um I have a a comment that was
sent in by uh representative Brian
Sullivan he was one of our seatmates so
could I read that please
um Brian says I'm deeply indebted to
Steve for the roles that I have played
in my seven years in the house after
serving a single year in the house Steve
surprised me by asking me to serve as
chair of the House labor committee I
pushed back a bit but his confidence in
me persuaded me to accept and I'm glad I
did for the last two years I've had the
honor and the privilege of being
seatmate to Steve the house
floor I so appreciated the wisdom the
history and most of all the humor that I
shared with Steve on my left and Linda
on my right it was a historic session in
so many ways and it's so precious to
share it with Steve and Linda Steve I
wish you all the best I hope that you
come back to the state house now and
again even if it's only to play with the
elevators good to end where you start
started wishing you all the best
representative Ryan
Sullivan very nice thank you
representative that was our last pink
card from committee uh however as you
all know as so often happens sometimes
people come in late and they submit pink
cards I have a few more um I have one
here from speaker uh Sher Packard and so
uh he's he is here uh Mr Speaker uh you
how formal should I be Mr
chairman uh we're relax We're uh
suspending the rules somewhat today Mr
Speaker so you have great Freedom great
leeway
um this is
Bittersweet uh Steve and I have been
friends for almost 20 years that we've
known each
other and
for the last six years when Steve was
speaker uh I used to meet with him once
a
week um you know to go over what was
happening that's when I was in the uh
minority office and Steve and I had some
terrific conversations because we both
love history and um we had some terrific
conversations about historical
figures and uh I'm going to miss those
my
friend
um the relationship I think that Steve
and I have
proves that you can disagree
on different subjects You can disagree
on philosophy but you can still be good
friends and I think that's what Steve
and I have been for the whole time that
he and I have been in the house together
um you can put the rhetoric side and you
can truly disagree philosophically
without being
disagreeable and for the past four years
that I've been speaker uh Steve and I
used to sit down and occasionally I'd
give him a call and I said want to come
in and talk for a few minutes and that
usually was about an hour and um I I'm
I'm going to miss those talks my friend
and
uh the house is losing a uh very
valuable
member um
but what can I say um I hope you're
enjoy your new job I I understand it
pays a little bit more than what you're
making
now yeah just just a little bit but of
course that won't take much to get paid
more than we have paid now but um I hope
you do well in your job uh as county
commissioner
uh I have a few things here I'm going to
uh I'd like to uh
read and then I have a presentation to
you this is a
declaration whereas the honorable Steven
J schliff is retiring from Public
Service as a state representative who
has served the community of marac
district 15 for 20 years whereas the
honorable Steven J Sheriff began his
career as a state representative in 2004
and served in the following capacities
Majority Leader minority leader speaker
of the house and most frequently speaker
of Meritus and that will probably be I
think you're the only one in the history
that has been given that
honor whereas The Honorable step J
sheriff is the only member of the New
Hampshire house to serve all four
leadership positions and hold a position
as a committee chair and whereas the
honorable Steven J shirtliff is a
Vietnam
veteran and a retired supervisor Deputy
United States
Marshall and whereas he has dedicated
countless hours to the advocacy for
veterans both here in New Hampshire and
Nationwide and has been their Champion
for accessible and care and benefits
declared that the new hire House of
Representative does give its highest
accolades and plotus to our former
speaker of the New Hampshire house our
esteemed colleague and mentor and friend
and be at further declare clared by
virtue of my signature below the New
Hampshire House of Representatives also
gives its best wishes to the honorable
Steven shlif in his new Endeavors his
legacy of hard work dedicated leadership
and bipartisanship will endure he will
be
missed and if you want to you want to
come up Steve I want to uh like to
I'd like you to present this St um for
your 20 years service
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker and represent
sherff shared that he uh was going to
call in for a sub for this uh this uh
session um Subs on state federal yes it
has happened uh but I'm we're all very
glad that Reb shli is here uh I do have
some more uh Pink cards that came in
late we're going to let everyone um as
is our custom in New Hampshire um well
Mr chairman I wouldn't approved
it uh well the the next pain card that I
have here and uh sometimes we do set
limits uh two to three minutes and uh
I'm not going to go there yet um because
the next speaker I think uh also rates
uh uh some whatever flexibility he
desires another speaker a former speaker
uh former speaker Sean Jasper is in the
speaker thank you Mr
chairman representative shirtliff former
speaker schliff I I really have to Echo
almost all of the comments that uh
speaker Packard made you and I had a
very similar
relationship um when I was speaker and
you were minority
leader but it goes well beyond that and
I'll go back uh just about 10
years and I think we all know what
happened in December of
2014 uh and if you don't you can ask
somebody but I always have uh plan a and
plan
B and so when I was running for speaker
plan a was to
lose Plan B was to win and wasn't a very
well-developed
plan but a very intrical part of my
becoming speaker was representative
shirtliffe who showed something that far
too few politicians in this country and
I've thought of this a lot when we've
seen what happened with the speaker's
race in Washington uh several times now
that Steve schliff
put politics
well below what he saw and I believed as
well was best not only for the New
Hampshire legislature but for the people
of New Hampshire and he rallied his
caucus um to support me and he didn't
ask for anything in return other than
that his caucus be treated with fairness
and that's what I tried to do but I
don't think there's anything better that
you can say about a person particularly
one in politics other than that he
believed that putting the state in the
legislature
first was his
duty and I think he's done that
throughout his career listen to him
frequently on the radio when I'm driving
up to conquer in the morning and he's
always taken that that position and that
is really something that is far too rare
today he really has my undying respect
for what he's done over the years and I
am even as a a republican very glad that
he got to serve as speaker and certainly
uh think he is welld deserving of that
first title of speaker am
Meritus there is one thing that I'm very
very jealous of Steve for though however
good well you
know that's that's funny because when he
became speaker and I was commissioner
people were constantly referring to me
as Steve and
so um you know it's funny that
back with the story I'm about to to tell
we both just had mustaches and here we
are today with our beards uh so we could
probably be uh here brothers and we said
that brothers from another mother but
when the State House Dome was being
refur refurbished and the the eagle was
stripped and was just you know didn't
look very pretty at the time but there
was an opportunity to go all the way up
and stand next to the eagle Steve was in
the state house and I grabbed him and uh
we went up to the top and stood there
and uh Jim Rivers was up there taking
pictures he later photoshopped so I had
a gold helmet on and Steve had a white
one on and that got photoshopped my
difference and but what I'm jealous
about is that I then had a conference to
go to and the Eagle was finished and all
gilded and Steve got to go back up there
again and have his picture taken with
the Gilded eagle and by the time I got
back from my trip the uh the staging was
gone but Steve thank you for your years
of of friendship and for
your showing people exactly what public
service is all about you've done it in
so many ways for your whole life you're
going to continue to do that as a County
Commission
and um you are just really to be
applauded thank you so much for being my
friend thank you Mr Speaker would you
take any would you take any questions or
comments if there is maybe one of course
Mr
chairman uh just two things about Sean
Jasper uh first of all when I was a
minority
leader uh New England cable news came to
me and said uh Mr Speaker we'd like to
ask you a question about uh was a bill
that was very important to Democrats to
be defeated and Republicans to be passed
and I said what a golden opportunity and
I said no I can't I said no I'm not the
speaker uh I'm Steve sherff I'm I'm
Democrat and so uh but uh it was a test
to my ethics but the other thing I want
to say is about speaker Jasper I went to
him one time short after he won his
election and uh and I said Mr Speaker
this is a bill that I know is important
to our Democratic
caucus I hope that if it comes to a
point that you can vote one way or the
other you'll support us and support this
legislation and I remember there are
people in his caucus that felt
differently about it and the vote came
up and we all looked up at the score and
it was a tie vote and all eyes were on
speaker Jasper and uh he voted with us
Democrats it was a bill dealing with
Healthcare and the bill passed by that
um you know I was shocked but then again
I wasn't because he speaker Jasper like
speaker packet they both have always
been people of their word and
uh it's so easy to be magnanimous and to
do the right thing when you deal with
people that share your same value value
so thank you Mr Speaker thank you Mr
you okay we have a few more pink cards
uh we have a uh individual here who has
asked for two minutes and that would be
the minority leader representative from
welcome thank you Mr chairman esteemed
members of the committee uh
representative shirtliff you have served
uh many roles in this uh esteemed
institution system assistant Majority
Leader chair of the criminal justice and
Public Safety Committee uh Majority
Leader minority
leader speaker of the house and now
speaker
ameritus I also have the honor uh like
representative mamila and representative
Sullivan of sitting next to uh the
speaker during session and uh learned so
much uh By asking questions uh by
getting unsolicited advice and
feedback
uh and learned so much about the history
of the New Hampshire house in the state
of New
Hampshire um during my first term uh
when representative sherli was serving
as speaker um I sat in the back row and
uh to keep myself uh entertained and to
be reporting to
constituents uh about what was going on
in the house I would tweet from time a
time uh and I started a hashtag called
shirtliff isms uh which were uh little
nuggets of humor that uh speaker
shirtliff would share uh during session
today uh so one from June 27th
2019 uh speaker schliff said I recently
had a minor operation on my right knee
apparently it was all those years of
break dancing that finally caught up
with
me May 23rd
2019 I worked for 30 years in law
police uh April 11th
2019 the speaker would never refer to
worms and uh March 20th
escapes Mr
Speaker uh I have a plaque
here it says Representative Steve
shirtliff speaker am Meritus with
gratitude and appreciation from your
colleagues in the New Hampshire house
Democratic caucus the New Hampshire
House of Representatives and the people
another
photo and by the way I I mentioned
earlier in committee that many of us uh
our history people in this committee we
had a interim study measure on the USS
Liberty we talked about the history I
believe that this uh this is still being
recorded I believe if it is uh there's a
lot of history that's being uh put on
the worldwide web via YouTube that I
think some future historians will be uh
very much interested to uh to to see or
hear and representative Sher this is
something you may or may not ever want
to watch this but uh I think it is being
recorded for posterity okay moving right
along uh we have a few more pink cards
The Honorable margerie Porter is in the
house uh former representative from
reporter I got a big chair here for
me thank
you Mr chair and members of the
committee and speaker shirtliff um I'm
not going to talk long I only asked for
a minute but I wanted to say thank you
to Steve for teaching
me the rules for
voting vote your
conscience vote your District vot your
party and I tried to follow those rules
and I thank him very much for sharing um
and I still owe you an Italian meal and
I'm going to hold you to it this time
Steve okay thank you for all you've done
for everybody thank you so
much thank you former representative I
have a card here from David Welch is
sure looks slightly different from the
last time that I saw uh The Honorable
David welz welcome back
well thank you Mr chairman uh if you've
noticed somebody is supporting a beard
and I don't have
one and now originally I was under the
weather when Linda called me and I had
to prepare a letter for her to read in
my
place but I can do it
now so this is dear
Linda I want to thank you for giving me
the opportunity to comment about my
friend Steve
sherff as you may know he became
chairman of the house criminal justice
committee a few years ago realizing that
as a former Federal Marshal he had no
clue whatsoever about criminal
law he sat me near his share so that I
could prompt him from time to time that
was advantageous as he needed a lot of
prompting as a term ground on he must
have realized that his expertise was
telling everyone what to do so
eventually he became speaker of the
house I was familiar with Steve by now
and realized that he needed no prompting
I always thought that Steve was an
honorable man so imagine my surprise
when he in front of everyone sto by
Thunder by vacating the chair in order
to cast a deciding vote on the repeal of
the death
penalty I had been a supporter of the
death penalty for almost 30 years and
now I had decided to support repeal I
think it was an override vote we
overrode the governor's veto by one vote
it was my vote that did it not his I
really can't forgive him for
that his true nature has become clear
now he's running for an office that pays
a
salary on top of that he chose an
opponents there is no joy in Mudville as
he hurdles onward to ad higher office
again I thank him for the opportunity to
clear the air I wish Steve all the best
as he delves in the County government I
take hat that he cannot boss anyone
around or steal
votes Steve is an honorable man and all
kidding aside he deserves his chance and
an administrative job I'm proud to call
friend thank you thank you honorable
David wel you take any questions or
comments
why not are there any questions or
comments for the uh speak I have a brief
one thank you for asking
um it was in my third term when I became
the chair of the criminal justice
committee and David was a longtime chair
of that committee and uh then became the
ranking member and if anybody was a
mentor to me in the New Hampshire house
it was David uh so often I would ask him
for advice and as like they alluded to
earlier when Larry spoke David and I
reached an agreement that neither side
would caucus that year we'd take the
votes up as they came and uh speaker
narelli kept calling me into her office
and saying you're not caucusing with the
Democrats on criminal justice I said
well no well she say stop doing it and I
said I can't I gave David Welch my word
and I can't go back on it well that's
you know and for the rest of that
session we did our caucus and David even
to this day is still a role mod and am
Meed to me and I thank him for
everything and anything I've achieved
achieved is because of his help and his
guidance and thank you for being here
today my friend
oh I I have one comment when speaker
narelli became
speaker it was a first for many years
and I went to the speaker and I said you
know when we train the
chairman who's going to train the
chairman so I to go in and train the
chairman and representative noes uh
became the chair chair of the criminal
justice committee that year and
uh it it was it was a good good
relationship I got along I got along
good with everyone well I'll just add to
that when speaker narali followup thank
you Mr
chairman I'll never Mass these rules um
when speaker nalii became the speaker in
2006 she was the first Democratic
speaker since before the American Civil
War so there was not a lot of knowledge
out there for Democrats and I attended
your training over at the New Hampshire
Technical Institute and you were so kind
and our caucus so appreciated you been
think it was over two hours talking to
us about the committee process and about
legislation and it was so insightful and
that's the kind of person you are again
to steal a line from speaker Jasper
putting people in government above
politics and uh and I commit you for
that thank you my friend thank you see
thank
you okay next pink card is from a
sitting representative uh The Honorable
representative from Durham margerie
Smith is in the house welcome
[Applause]
thank you Mr chairman um I'm pleased to
say that I once had to I once chose to
sit at state and federal as a substitute
and I well remember the
experience with mixed feelings but I
I don't have to say much because for
those of you who are in the house I
think you heard what I had to say about
Steve um in the last day of the session
in
June
uh and what has transpired just now has
taken me down memory lane I've been here
since 1996 and have served under uh sha
who decided to punish me once and put me
on two
committees um I served under Steve who
uh did not want me to be the chair of
the committee I wanted to chair and in
return gave me another two positions in
order to help ease the pain um uh who
have I forgotten that's and um but
everything that has been said today
reflects something that I think I like
to think all of us believe at some level
and that is that personal
integrity and respect for each other and
treating each other honestly is much
more important than any piece of
legislation that we might disagree on
and if we can find a little bit just a
little corner where we agree and start
create a
change in the
climate in the N Hampshire house because
I believe a change would improve the
quality of of work for all of us and if
we were to do that it would be because
we understand
the value of the principles that Steve
schliff has inspired in all of us um and
he's not alone there's no question about
that but he is certainly first among
equals and um I don't quite know what
we'll do with that you Steve but we're
going to try to muddle through thank you
thank you
representative will you take any
questions or comments um if that
appropriate of course we uh yes I have
the gavel yes um are there any questions
or comments for the representative from
Durham representative Smith had such a
great reputation when I came to this
house and
um and when I was speaker I did ask her
to go on a committee that I know wasn't
her first choice but because of the
circumstances she did it and she did it
so well
I started out on the Judiciary Committee
and I think your F first committee is
always a special place in your heart and
Judiciary meant so much to me and I
thought of the possibilities of other
people taking that chair and I couldn't
think of anybody better than
representative Smith to carry on the
strong tradition of uh bipartisanship
fairness on a very important committee
and again I thank her from the bottom of
my heart instead of doing what she
wanted to do doing what she felt was the
best thing to do under the circumstances
again for our state in our New Hampshire
legislature so thank you
MRE thank you Mr thank
you okay I have I have four more uh Pink
cards uh one has asked for one minute
three minutes and the other two didn't
have any limit uh so we will head down
the home stretch here uh representative
Lehman Peter leechman is he's still yes
he is welcome representative
lean thank you Mr
chairman first I want to say thank you
Steve for those of you that really don't
know the Steve Sheriff like I do I've
served in the house now finishing up 12
terms and Steve has always been a
Workhorse and not a show horse uh the
division I've been on in finance deals
with Veterans Affairs and Steve was
always there whispering in my ear trying
to get things done for the veterans the
National Guard and I thank you for that
Steve there was one other issue that
Steve worked very hard on this last term
and that was funding the retirees that
lost their benefits more than a decade
ago there were about 1,600 of them and
with Steve's help and the other members
we got a bill through the house for $26
million to help fund those people that
lost their benefits more than a decade
ago so thank you for that Steve and I am
really going to miss you
representative okay Representative Bob
Lynn representative Lynn is he was there
he is welcome representative Lynn The
wendam thank you Mr chair um I I I think
I probably have the honor or or at least
I hope I I I'm pretty sure I have the
honor of of being able to say that that
from what I've heard of all the other
speakers I've probably known Steve
longer than than anyone here because my
my first interaction with Steve goes
back if you can believe this 46 years to
1978 when I had just come to New
Hampshire as an assistant us attorney
and Steve I believe was relatively new
uh in the US Marshals office uh in in
New Hampshire uh and Bob re uh who just
recently passed away uh wonderful guy um
was the United States Marshall at the
time and Bill Shaheen who hired me was
the US attorney at the time um and I
remember one one of the things I
remember in particular about Steve is as
I recall there was a there was a um a
Personnel shortage General I think
generally in the Marshall service and so
that meant that Mar Deputy Marshals were
being sent around the country to travel
transporting prisoners and this and that
much more frequently than uh had sort of
normally been the case and so Steve was
all when I would be talking to him he
was always I got I'm going to be on a
plane tomorrow to you know Tim Buck two
to transport somebody somewhere it was
uh just seemed to me like a very you
know a very difficult time uh for in
terms of sort of personal uh uh
sacrifices that people had to make but
Steve always you know did it with a with
a smile and just that was was part of
what he had to do uh but I remember my
interactions with him then were always
just wonderfully friend he was just
wonderfully friendly and and and
courteous and and helpful and then I
when I moving back moving on a number of
years when I I was uh in the uh in the
court system and particularly when I
served as as Chief Justice of both the
superior court and then later the
Supreme Court I had occasions to deal
with Steve um and particularly when he
was speaker on things dealing with the
budget those kind of things again uh
always uh you know
straightforward uh if he told you
something you could take it to the bank
and it was just a wonderfully positive
relationship and in the in my relatively
brief time in the house the last four
years again nothing but completely
positive um relationship it's just been
a real pleasure uh uh to have the
opportunity to work with you Steve and I
I'm uh your your record of public
service is just outstanding and I wish
you the very best and marac County um
will be will be very well served with
your working uh with your new position
as County Commissioner so again thank
you very much for your service over all
the these so many years thank you thank
you
representative thank you Mr chairman you
know it's hard to believe how Bob back
uh the chief and I go and uh and he
hasn't changed a bit which drives me
crazy but um just as young as today as
he was then and and back then I I I
think that us attorney's office uh had
to have been the finest law firm in the
state of New Hampshire at the time with
the quality of prosecutors and uh and
Bob Lynn is a prime example and the
number of cases they handled in the
intricacies and the types of crimes um
and to watch Bob how he has progressed
up through the New Hampshire
court system to become chief justice and
to see him come back here to this body
to finish uh to
serve it just bolds well that the
quality of people that run for the New
Hampshire house and I think a lot of the
public must wonder sometimes how can you
pay somebody $100 a year and expect your
quality people uh that put dedication
and service above uh uh financial gain
and Bob is a prime example of that and
it's uh that to me is the true New
Hampshire advantage and it's so good to
have Bob back and uh and thank you for
your very kind words oh thank thank you
also thank you thank
[Applause]
you okay uh Dan Mason has asked for
three minutes is Dan here yes he
is motion to
thank you to the committee here um so
unlike everyone else that has come up to
testify before I'm a member of the staff
so a little different a little nervous
up here so please please bear with me um
I've had the privilege of serving on the
staff in the Democratic office um since
uh 2006 so um middle of uh speaker shtle
of second term and um so I've known
speaker shler for a very long time and
you know of course before he was speaker
he was Democratic leader or majority
leader shirtliff for a number of terms
and then uh chair shirtliff before that
and so we had a lot of time um that he
he was in the Democratic office because
his leader he was someone that was here
all the time uh always present in the
building and as everyone in this room
probably knows in politics A lot changes
over the course of a decade or you know
15 years and you have some days that are
really good and things are going really
well and then some days that are really
bad and you know um you know out there
in the world and you know things aren't
going you're not feeling very good um
and so what I you know the point I'm I
want to make is that every day day in
day out we would come to work and you
were there courteous kind you know just
you know always with a smile on your
face a witty thing to say to to help us
feel better and you know it over the
course of Time how people that come into
work every day in an environment you
really want leaders in front of you that
you know make you feel good about it and
we always had that with you as leader um
no matter what role you were in and I
just you know speaking for all the
Democratic office staff and I I can't
imagine I that I W also be speaking for
the overall staff in the building so I
just want to say thank you for the way
you treated us over the time and you
know best of luck and thank you thank
you
Dan
okay okay uh some of you remember the
the tonight's show uh Ed McMahon would
do a thing with johonny Carson some of
you may remember and to paraphrase Ed
McMahon I have in my hand the last pink
card um and before I go to the the last
pink card uh I'd like to just remind the
uh committee members uh a message came
from um an office somewhere uh asking
that we clean out our desks and
drawers uh so just a reminder if you
haven't already done so I saw that
representative shirtliff you were doing
that earlier I think I said that clear
you know make sure you clear that out so
thank you for jumping on that so uh
please take care of that also uh before
we leave Deb's still here if if you
wouldn't mind committee members like we
did last year if we get a a photo real
quick right up front here um and there
is the rules have been suspended uh
there are Refreshments in room 210 I
believe uh so uh it's almost noon so
after our final speaker uh everyone is
welcome to uh please stop down there and
have some refreshments okay uh last pink
card representative ghoul welcome glad
you're
here thank you and it's a great pleasure
to be here I wanted to speak to
something that I think has been hinted
about but not really laid out on the
table and that is about representative
Sheriff humility and so um a couple of
years ago before I was elected I've only
served the one term I had the privilege
to play with a great cast of characters
in a cemetery walk in
hackington and the director was uh Peter
Spalding's wife Beth Spalding so it's
interesting the county commissioner
connection but at any rate uh I was
amazed at what incredible actors they
were and having a love of history and
Native American history that we share um
I just saw Steve as another talented
actor then I was elected I came to the
house and here was this wonderful Man
Who Loved history and loved Native
Americans and he was very uh revered
here in the house it was clear I didn't
put two and two together this year we
started um our our rehearsals for the
play we're doing this weekend and I saw
him and I was shocked because the Two
Worlds collag I still didn't remember he
was from the previous cast and I said oh
Mr Speaker it's so good to see you here
tonight and he said yeah I figured I'd
come back and then I realized so dear I
acted with him two years ago and didn't
put it together but he was so humble he
said I'm easily forgettable it's okay
representative G you are not at all
easily
forgettable and uh in his character
they've got him scripted to talk about
his character you won't be shocked to
hear was a representative from
hopkington sent to conquer and they're
having him say delegate and it's not a
delegate so a man of his stature should
not be expected to say the wrong script
my mission this afternoon is to get that
script changed for him so he can give an
accurate portrayal of our role here
emirus thank you representative G if you
would you hit hit that red button please
um so that was our last pink card we do
have two or three people going to make
some quick calls uh representative Massa
Miller is driving this uh she'll put the
calls on speaker and they will be
um you can yeah you can go right there
uh to uh one of these calls I heard may
be coming from Trump Force One I'm not
sure uh but uh but uh you laugh but uh
uh representative Mass Miller she's
going to work the technology we have a a
phone speaker going to work the
technology you just need to put your
phone on speaker call the person and and
let and hold the hold the phone up to
the mic with the red light on okay we'll
good to
go and I think you'll recognize all okay
go
ahead you can go
ahead thank
you this is abely wonderful i' let there
uh get me in the loop um the only story
I could get I could give
is uh what you've taught me through
through your leadership as the minority
leader and as the uh speaker of the
house um and one of those greatest uh
gifts that I've gotten from you is uh
decorum I recall has the minority leader
uh you would push the chorum I didn't
know how to spell it so I wasn't
interested in it uh however however
however through through your leadership
I learned it well um especially you know
you didn't expect the chorum you
demanded it that's and that was the big
uh initiative that uh that gave me that
that teaching and and I absolutely
appreciate that uh through through our
relationships uh building um you you you
are always above everyone else in my
opinion um and I thank you for those
lessons learned that I continue to uh
call on to and and I constantly remember
where that came from and that did come
from you Steve so thank you very much
thanks so much Pat I wish you very the
very best in the future and I'll just
let it go that you also Steve thank you
I was happy to be in on this thanks P
thanks P thank you represent thank you
represent M Miller great job with that
technology uh we have one or two more
calls uh I don't know if the Trump for
course one call is going to be last uh
represent Massa Miller is driving this
this final piece of the uh of our of our
uh session a non-traditional session
obviously and and thank you Mr Speaker
for letting us have uh uh the ability to
suspend the rules slightly to include
Refreshments one time yes say Mr Speaker
in three
heads hi
Laura hi this is Linda and say what you
Steve
go hi Steve a Blas me past oh
no oh yes oh no oh yeah David Welch is
with us also she knows oh really okay
yeah and his wife no no that's
what what would you like to say to
Steve I just going to say that they can
lose an awful good leader from the house
when he moves but I wish him luck in his
commission
show well Laura panelas although
somebody has else has the title now is
Dean of the house to me you will always
be the dean and uh uh this is
representative Laura panel
loas was my vice chair when I chaired uh
uh criminal justice so was the tro here
myself Laura and David and uh thank you
Laura and we all want myself and David
and uh and Linda want to get over to try
to see you sometime
soon I'd love that so would we good good
luck to you and have a great time with
one more Laura pinak is former uh the
longest serving member last term okay
the last note that I have uh I'm not
sure what's going to happen here has
something to do with a possible call
from Trump Force One I don't know what
representative Massa Miller is going to
H have happen here but this uh if
there's a connection this will be our
while she is working the diligently uh
reminder to the committee members for
afterwards the president's tied there's
technical things I don't know that it's
the president I I it it may be uh I I do
hi this is Al at this time I am probably
in the pool or hanging out somewhere
please leave a message I'll get back to
you as soon as possible thank
you H what are you doing you're supposed
to be
Marine yes good the first sergeant will
need to stand by for a counseling
session um okay that wraps up and going
to wield the gavel thank you Deb for
taking our picture we'll see those of
you uh who can make it down in 210 for
some um uh Refreshments uh because the
rules have been suspended um last call
anybody in committee with with anything
uh representative
gagy yes
uh okay Mo do we do I hear a mo motion
to adjourn so move wait uh yeah I
represent uh Mr Vice chair go
ahead thank you Mr chairman one last
thing to wrap up something I forgot uh
one last dig it Steve last week when we
get we're at the L we came in we were
having a talk and I asked him I said how
how's your election going he says well
he says I think it's going pretty good
he said I'm running unopposed I said
well I said I I think it's going to be
close but I think you can pull it
out thank you my friend thank you
all thank you Mr chairman thank
you